this is so exciting i don't think we've
ever had a rock star in the room before
so
uh we are reeling we have lots of rock
star entrepreneurs and venture
capitalists
but this is exciting so uh is this your
first time at stanford
yeah you still don't have a rockstar no
yeah yeah yeah i think we'll
uh yeah yeah okay so here we have
cameron here we have nate and in fact uh
nate this morning got a chance to go
play golf at the stalford golf course
yeah
pretty cool amazing one of them yeah i
was just like
bumming around in florida and and other
places and
um to come here is just incredible
fabulous as an excuse that you know i'm
only here because i was able to play the
golf course earlier
great well maybe we can entice you back
again probably
so let's get started a lot of people in
the room are not that familiar with the
music industry we're certainly pretty
familiar with the silicon valley
entrepreneurial ecosystem maybe you
could give us a little bit of a tutorial
about what it means to be a producer
a manager a executive and also an artist
in the music industry
cameron you want to kick it off well
i'll start quickly so
um the music business the music business
is
uh really you know divided into major
companies and independent companies
and now the major companies are really
warner music group
which uh i'm a part of uh sony and
universal
and and then there's a whole host of
independent companies
that are that are smaller than the
majors and generally
you know on the uh the business is
divided into
uh recorded music which is the the kind
of the classic record business where we
find artists
we make recordings of the music and we
exploit that music
however we can you know through through
cd sales through downloads through
streaming
through licensing of all different types
and also the music publishing business
which
isn't really the music publishing
business it's called the music
publishing business because
you know 100 200 years ago they used to
publish sheet music but really today
it's more probably the music licensing
business and the song
business and that business is about um
owning and managing the underlying songs
the the intellectual property of the
songs themselves the compositions
themselves so
every song's written by somebody and
they own that song and then it's it's
used in various ways so
you know that's that's the music
business that we're in and then there's
artists and managers and booking agents
and lawyers
there's a whole industry of people that
make a living
working around the music business and
artists and songwriters
right from the artist perspective i am
the exploited
it's a terrible word so i
don't exploit the music the managers
everybody uh
i i create music make art um
write songs it's they're not uh mutually
exclusive or
together art or or music um
and i like to to do a little bit of
everything and
and uh that usually means that
eventually i have to go out on tour
or uh do interviews or do other stuff
like that but um
but the music industry where i'm at
right now
is a great place because because um you
know i've had opportunities i've been on
the radio and
have sold music so so to get to
i guess um dictate
have a little more of a hand in
dictating what what what i do as an
artist is it's a great place to be
so around here we know about all
different types of investors you know
whether it's seed funds that
really look at companies very early on
and those who invest later stage
at what stage do you start investing in
in artists
and and is maybe you could tell you a
little bit about how you were discovered
and
and i mean you were really young when
you first got your first record contract
yeah i was uh i was 18 years old
playing in a local local band in phoenix
and
and the radio station had started to
play our music and
major labels had caught caught wind of
it and next thing you know we're signing
a big contract and um when you sign a
contract that's too big
and you don't sell a lot of albums you
end up getting dropped
and then i was resigned by the same
company about four years later
um in a different band which is it's a
very weird
you know i guess just never giving up
and and i've always had some sort of
cult fan base to to rely on which is an
important thing um
it's an important thing you know i
talked about how it's easier to make
decisions now
um after you've kind of made it a little
bit but but it's also wonderful to to
step out onto your own
and and and uh i guess not be as reliant
on
on on the big companies though uh
i think it took a lot of a lot of
failing uh to to appreciate what
what a company like like warner um
whether it be the publishing or or the
record
companies can do for you when you're
ready to um
we're gonna keep saying exploited which
i think we need to just like we need to
erase that work okay i'm like absolutely
my fault that's my fault so maybe you
could talk a little bit about it
cameron about you know at what stage
you're looking for artists are you
trying to find the folks who are
you know in a small club or a coffee
shop playing a guitar
or are you looking for people who have a
big fan base already
online well there's no real you know
there's no real one recipe
so we are generally just looking for
very talented people who
we think will connect with an audience
and
you know sometimes that's sometimes they
have big fan bases sometimes they have
small fan bases
i think one of the things about the
company you know when you're a company
as big as warner's is
we're dealing with all different types
of artists so you know
um to put it in perspective on uh on at
the publishing company
you know we we publish everybody from
you know the gershwins to cole porter to
radiohead to lil wayne to
to nate ruth to um
jay-z and beyonce and katy perry so you
know we've got a wide array of people
doing a lot of different things some of
them are current with huge fan bases
some of them
are are historic with with huge cat song
catalog
so you know there's a there's a there's
a lot of um
a lot of nuance to dealing with the
various people
but when it comes to finding talent and
developing artists and
and investing in people's careers
we're looking for them at whatever phase
they're at
you know i think some sometimes we we're
very early
and sometimes it takes somebody a period
of time to
you know to be ready and to be on the in
a place where
where it makes sense can you talk a
little bit about the relationship
how much shaping gets done of the artist
one of the things i've learned about in
getting to know the company over the
last few weeks
is the term um anr how many in the room
have heard of the term a and r
okay a couple of people okay and this
was a fascinating concept maybe you
could talk about that
that process and how that fits into sort
of
working with the artists and ours i mean
originally stood for artists and
repertoire
and really that's the part of the
company that creatively works with
artists
and or songwriters on the publishing
side but let's just stick to the record
side so
that's the side that that finds artists
that brings them to the company that
uh eventually you know hopefully we sign
a contract with the artist and then
works with them
too to get the recordings done to help
help them connect to the company in such
a way that we can connect them to an
audience
so sometimes again you know there's no
one-size-fits-all sometimes the
the artists are are you know um
have a very clear artistic vision and
and write and
and perform their own material and some
are
are not songwriters at all but have an
artistic you know
take on on music and how they what they
want to perform so
we may help them connect with
songwriters or record producers
or songs themselves that people send us
so
there's there's a variety of things that
that a r does depending on
on on what the artist needs one of the
things that i've learned along the way
is that it's actually pretty rare to be
in a position like you nate where you
actually are a songwriter and
a performer that a huge number of people
fit into one of those categories you
know either
a songwriter or a performer and that's
where this comes a matching
as a songwriter and a performer what
sort of
relationship do you have how much
shaping do you get
in in of your work or are you given a
lot of um artistic and creative freedom
well a lot of artistic and creative
freedom and and that's
i don't think i was going to sign
another contract with a major label in
this it was something that i was going
to get because
as cameron mentioned it it's it's good
to have an a r for for someone who
might need a little bit of shaping you
know um when i look at a lot of artists
and if i'm critical i think like oh well
they could use a little bit of a r in
this department or that department
um i think for us uh
you know we're we're a confident bunch
uh i had made
i'd seen the the the problems that i'd
had in the past uh
you know artist development is is a very
crucial thing and it's not something
that
necessarily happens a lot these days and
i think that that's why we're seeing a
lot of bands just
come and go or artists just come and go
they don't get an opportunity to develop
and uh and i think that we
through the trials and tribulations to
where i am now um
you know when when uh we'd written and
and recorded that last album we didn't
have an anr
uh because it was we knew what we wanted
to do we were very
like you know you have a specific goal
but
that's usually not the case
so usually um artists take full
advantage of these type of
resources i mean if yeah they can they
can be helpful i
i had a r on my first album on a major
label 10 years ago and it was
just a disaster you know and like
the people talking to you about about
the songs that you're writing as
a i think as a as a band member or as an
alternative musician or something like
that
you look at it a little bit different
you know i've written songs for other
artists
and um it's been set up by a r people um
you know those songs probably wouldn't
happen if it wasn't for for a
r whereas i'm not looking for any
outside help in songwriting so
so i don't i don't need that but when
you hear like from an a r guy and he's
what do you say on when i'm making my oh
i was making my first album
i was about 19 or 20 and he was you know
it just needs to be a little more high
octane
you know and it's just
i'm not gonna cuss otherwise we have to
label it explicit
oh that's true in everything right there
so good a
r doesn't use words like exploited
we were talking we were talking actually
earlier today and we were talking about
the good
ideas and the bad ideas so maybe there's
good a r
out of bad a and rn
well so one of the things that we're
very aware of here is
technology trends and things are
changing all the time that's certainly
true in the music industry as well
how do you both follow and create
trends
uh well i i don't do either one so
um but generally i'm buying those shoes
tomorrow
yeah but as a company
you know i i think it's a little bit
counterintuitive you know because
um it's uh and i think it really relates
to creativity and it relates to
to being an entrepreneur or you know
anything that's truly creative
it's the the challenge is you know how
to remain fresh and creative and new in
your approach
so that uh you know you're not following
you're not chasing something that's
already being done you're actually doing
something new
and i think for for you know for a
company or for an artist or for
uh you know that's that's just a huge
challenge
and it's a it's it's an it's an exciting
challenge and it's one of those things
when you experience it it's it's really
fantastic and i think it's what keeps us
all trying and keeps us all going back
because you know i'm i'm amazed every
year or
you know put whatever time frame you
want on it i tend to use years i guess
because that's the way we delineate our
life in some fashion but
you know every year the songs are are
great every year there's more
hit songs every year there's a song i
hear or a bunch of songs that i hear
that move me emotionally and
make me you know want to listen to music
or play it for my friends or play for my
family
and those songs usually don't sound like
the songs that i heard last year
so it's um it's uh you know that's
that's the challenge that's the
that's the infinite challenge that we
have in the music
world do you think about this do you
think about trends
or are you as an artist um
trying to buck the trends and trying to
do something that's very different
no i i think that it's it's um
as an artist you know i think that i
didn't necessarily have the maybe the
mainstream success that
i had until recently because i was so
caught up in trying to kind of
just make albums like from the 60s or
70s like beatles-esque
type of albums and and i started to just
lose focus on what was happening now and
i think with the last album i had
i'd realized that i was just going to
get left behind if i wasn't going to
start paying attention and
you know there's a lot of terrible music
out there most of it is terrible
um but there's but there's a lot of good
stuff and there's there's people trying
to do
to do new things and and
and i i let it influence me
i've become better a better songwriter
just a better person by acknowledging
what what's happening right now
you know i think it used to just kind of
scare me a little bit but but now i i
think that it's it's
been one of the biggest reasons for my
success is to
acknowledge that there's something in
front of me and it's happening
speaking of albums people are consume
songs these days you know as well as
albums
do you think about this do you think in
terms of developing a whole album
a whole collection or do you think about
you know one hit at a time
i think about i think strictly about uh
an album
that's how i was raised with my dad's
record collections um
they got to tell a story you know that's
right now i'm in the process of making
an album
and and the biggest challenge for me is
is
the cohesiveness that's with the album
it's not about writing a song i mean
that's
you know that's a little bit easier it's
it's or it's
it's a lot easier than than thinking
about tying this whole entire thing
together and how it's going to affect
someone's life as opposed to
just that that one little song whereas
like you know in publishing
it's a lot different you are a lot of it
is based just around one song a lot of
the success
is based around one song and that i mean
it makes total sense
um i i was talking earlier about about
other songs that i'd written and
and how i might not you know think that
it's it's
i'm not breaking any new ground and uh a
lot of times as a songwriter i'll take
my name off of the song and put a
different name under the song and um
that's just a little fun for me because
i like to see
how far up the song will get uh and not
have
like it and not be kind of associated
with it but uh
but at the end of the day i think that
it's important people work too hard and
it's weird to be judgey um
you know if like i i try not to to
formula like to say
you know call a song out specifically
because someone might love it and
someone works really hard and they might
get into their car
after a long day and that what i
consider to be a mindless song might
come on and it's it's inspirational it's
great for them
do you think differently about this the
songs well you know
i think nate hit made a good point in
publishing it's definitely about the
songs we manage the songs individually
but um yeah we think about it
24 7 songs albums singles i mean
it's it's an ongoing discussion and
you know which song which is the single
which which formats it radio all of
those kinds of things
um so we you know it's one of the
uh one of the the real um
one of the real influences of technology
on music is is the way people
experience and consume the music and
that affects how they listen to it how
they engage with it
how we connect artists to fans and
that's
sometimes it's about whether they listen
to whole albums or not or buy whole
albums
so speaking of technology yeah i mean
we've got these cultural changes that
are going on but we also have
huge technical changes technological
changes that are happening around us
and certainly are affecting the music
industry
is i'm assuming you think about this all
the time is this
is this an exciting time to be in music
industry with all these technical
changes
yes i mean it is it's an exciting time
there's no no question and i think it's
probably more exciting
today than it was you know a number of
years ago
because our music industry as a whole
has shrunk
frankly over the last decade so it's
much smaller than it was 10 years ago
um for a whole host of reasons one of
them i think
is is the way technology's affected
people consuming music
but on the other hand it's growing in a
different way so it's really just
it's changed you know the the record
business per se has gotten smaller
but the music business as a whole has
gotten bigger so
the challenge you know to some degree
for companies like ours is how do we go
from being a record company to being a
music company
and what does that mean and and how
how do we look at that so it's a it's a
time of great change which is really
exciting
um but also you know it's challenging
i remember 10 years ago um being
like having just started and i think i
had gotten one of the last
big contracts that that uh that they
were giving out to bands at the time
and it was it was just insane to see
that that year i think it was 2002
to 2003 and and itunes took over
and everything everything changed and
we started to realize that we weren't
gonna necessarily have a job
as a band unless we got out on the road
and we made our money by touring and
stuff like that so
we had to we had to find ways and
meanwhile i'm looking at the the music
industry and the people at our label at
the time
and they couldn't figure out how to
adjust
um we were thankful to be dropped by
them because we were
we're watching them flailing uh you look
at people like cameron now and
and we've got another friend who they're
embracing it and you're you're seeing
the turnaround now
because of because of people like
cameron
you know for me it's it just personally
in my life um
you know you know i'm an entrepreneur
really i mean i've i've worked at one of
music group for three years but prior to
that
i'd only worked for myself so um
in the music business so when i started
my company it was a record company
and in 1999 2000 is when we started to
see the decline of cd sales and
and the the explosion of technology with
with um
itunes in fact i was then i i
came up to cupertino to see and i was at
the theater at
apple when steve jobs introduced itunes
to the music industry
so i i was sitting in a theater about
this big
but um you know what it did for me is it
made me start
music publishing so it was a big driver
for me to change our business model and
to find some new things to do so
i started a music publishing company
probably within about 12 months
to determine how can we how can we
you know diversify as an entrepreneur as
somebody who's running a business with
22 employees
um you know how what are we going to do
with this coming and
with the change the disruption that's
going to occur i think it's very
interesting the reframing of saying
we're not in the record business we're
in the music business
and what new opportunities that opens up
in fact
almost everyone can be in the music
business right every kid in their
bedroom or their garage can put together
a band or sit in front of their computer
and make music
what do you think about that is that a
great thing is that a is that a
scary thing for a business that that uh
used to sort of control the whole
process
i think it's a great thing i mean to me
the more people that are engaged with
music the more people that you know one
of the biggest
uh i think you know one of the biggest
issues i have in my life and i'm sure
for
a lot of the people here is you know how
to how do you find the time
to uh to listen and to engage with music
and
and how how are we going to engage
people
uh on an ongoing basis and and
um so the more people are involved the
more
they whether they start out playing an
instrument
um you know i always say for whether
it's the artists
the fans or the people that work at our
company you know
90 of us fell in love with music at some
point in our life
you know usually when we were young with
our family or maybe in our high school
years or when we're in college or
whatever
but that's what really drives us at at
the end of the day
so the more people that have that
passion and the more people that connect
to music
on an ongoing basis it's you know the
better for as far as i'm concerned
yeah i mean i think creating is is an
amazing thing i don't i don't
play an instrument um i just hear songs
in my head
and so i mean i i assume that it's
something that pretty much anybody
can do and and should do because it's
fun
great it's fun
i didn't cuss i just mouthed the cuss
and for me you know i just that you know
i don't play an instrument
i don't hear songs in my head but i hear
them after they're recorded
and i know what to do after that so what
are the biggest challenges i mean
our room is filled with all these
remarkable people and there are a lot of
people around the world who are going to
be listening to this
who are problem solvers and they are
music lovers
what are the biggest problems that are
facing the music industry these days and
and how would you hope that people would
think about trying to tackle them
uh i'll take that one i guess biggest
problems basically
i thank you i didn't want to answer that
question i was looking at you
um uh well look we've got lots of
problems uh you know and i i think
it's something we talked about before i
mean i i try not to get bogged down in
the problems
you know i think that we've got to look
at them as opportunities because i think
when we look at them as problems
suddenly it's like
you know we've got all these problems
but we have lots of opportunities i mean
we have technology
all the things that it brings how do we
monetize the music how do we
monetize our relationship with fans how
do we get more music to fans
how do we create a global company how do
we
how do we you know how do we find
talented songwriters how do we find
talented artists
how do we how do we connect those
artists and their music with the fans in
an efficient way
you know how how do we deal with
uh how do we deal with the
the um the different interests the
competing interests that that are
surrounding music you know
um the there's now you know there's
there's the dmca there's washington
there's legal issues there's
royalty issues there's all kinds of
things going on by far the most dynamic
time in the the music industry has ever
seen so
there's lots of lots of change and with
all that change comes
problems and opportunities and i think
that that's
you know that's what we're doing here
we're hoping that um
you know so that there's people here who
will find ways
to help us deal with all the things we
have to deal with because
you know we're at warner chapel a 200
year old company i was saying to
somebody earlier today we were
beethoven's publisher
so you know it's it's it's a it's with a
million 1.2 million copyrights under
management everything from all the
artists that i just described
that's a big job unto itself and then we
have to figure out what do we do in a
changing world how do we deal with that
and there's only so much time
in the day so um you know
how do we engage with really innovative
thinkers with young people who are
in college campuses who are who are
have their own experiences and their own
ideas so one of the things that makes
this a very robust
environment is the fact that there's a
lot of experimentation
and what comes along with that is
sometimes things don't work out as
expected sometimes people call that
failure and uh this is a sort of place
where we understand that
that's part of the part of the process
is that if you're not failing sometimes
you're not taking enough risks
is this something that the music
industry embraces the the
idea of experimentation and risk-taking
knowing that not everything is going to
work
as an artist yeah um i i
i i love the risk-taking aspect of it i
don't like
i don't even coming up trying to write
an album
you know following up the success of
this last one um
one of the one of the things that
excites me is just how
much how what how how much further i can
go
um and where i can go and and to limit
yourself
because because something worked is
is terrible it's like it's atrocious and
and i hope i hope
i hope that it fails and that i love it
more than i hope that it
it it it's great and i you know and it
sells a whole bunch and i don't like it
i think you know it for me it's hard to
talk about the industry as a whole
all the time because frankly i've never
worked at any of the other companies so
um
but for us as a company you know risk
taking is certainly something that we
encourage
i'm fortunate we have you know
relatively new ownership at warner music
group who are terrific
the guys who the people who i am who are
my bosses and who i report to
are extremely supportive of us taking
risks of
us taking chances um so
you know i think one of the one of the
things that
we define our company by is culturally
is having a culture
an entrepreneurial culture you know so
to us what does that mean and how do we
do it
it means you're taking risks it means
being fast it means
being experimental it means you know
trusting one another
decentralized approach to business a
flat organization
all of those things we try to bring to
bring to the company every day because
it's vital that we take risks and it's
certainly you know in our dna too i mean
every every new artist deal every
every time we spend uh you know from a
business perspective
every time we invest in a new artist or
we invest in new music or we
in marketing or promotion or all of
those things you know there's never any
guarantees the music business is
you know i always say that you know
google dueling banjos and give it a
listen it was a number one record
you know and uh it's it's there's all
kinds of things that happen
so we have to be flexible and we have to
be willing to take risk and
we have to um it's a very very
challenging thing
for a lot of people in business school
or you know for me when i was
learning the the amount of risk
that it takes to be an entrepreneur or
that it takes to
be in the music business is so much more
significant than
most other businesses that it takes a
certain
level of passion and faith
to really undertake it i mean it's uh
it's not it's
very different than finance it's very
different than banking you know it's
it's you're out on a ledge i i
i'll just say this i i often with people
who come to work at our company i often
say you know
there's there's a continuum of risk here
and
the artists are out here because you
know you've heard of the fear of public
speaking as people know
well just think of public speaking but
like having to write and read your own
poetry
and sing it and you know i mean it's
essentially
a very very risky undertaking and
and then there's you know at the other
end of
there's all the more traditional
industries and more traditional jobs and
and then those of us that work in the
music business or our entrepreneurs are
somewhere in between and that's where
you really have to um
you know follow that follow that passion
and follow the faith that it's going to
work out and
you know have some luck you know some of
it involves a little bit of luck once in
a while i
i it's an important
important thing i can't tell you how
many times i'd sit in the conference
room at my old company and everybody
would be looking at each other going
what are we going to do next year
you know and then something will come
along
a record will show up an artist will
show up a hit will
i'm about dueling banjo was that the
deliverance song
that was a hit i think did you publish
that one no you don't follow but
too bad we should give permission for it
to just be running right now
there's no reason why that song should
work context anything that did somehow
it tapped into something at the time so
let's dive into the creative process
so nate you're in a band that is a
pretty intense
creative uh group um
can you tell us a little bit about the
process
of working together as a band to
not only create a song produce a song
what does everyone bring to the table
and how the decisions get made in that
in that process well i think it takes a
lot of knowing what
kind of what people do do best um
uh you know the songs generally start in
my head and
uh you know i'll conceptualize
conceptualize them conceptualize kind of
the album
where it's going to go and then we'll
all get together and kind of
dissect it a little bit and make an
album from that and uh
and i think it works so well and fun
because because we know each other but
we're also such close friends that uh
you know i've been in writing sessions
with people that i can't stand in and
it doesn't doesn't help and i think to
to be around people that that you trust
that you know kind of what their
strengths are and and you kind of
there was a time early on in in the band
when when we would just
the two of us would leave the room when
when the one person was kind of doing
the thing that they specialize in
and it was just at the beginning of the
band because
it was so exciting for for us to come
back into the room
and hear what they had done because uh
while the songs
you know you generally start start with
with me um
it's cool to see kind of the arc they
take thereafter
very cool so i'm going to ask just a
couple more questions and open it up to
the audience so you can percolate on the
type of questions that you would like to
ask to
our guests so one thing that
strikes me these days it's very
different than when i listen to music is
that all
most songs come out with a video and
it's really interesting so
how does that affect you do you have to
think about the visuals that go along
with the song
while you're writing it is that
something that's part of it and does
that change your experience of
crafting the song as well as the folks
who are going to be listening to it
um me personally no i i don't
the video thing is more of like a
massive annoyance
um they have to like get in front of a
camera
and do stuff like that i i
i like the song i like my favorite part
about music isn't what i saw
uh it's what i heard and it's what what
i heard and how it me what it means to
me when you're seeing a video
uh and this is just purely artistic i'm
sure that you know there there are
reasons why we make videos and it's
they're all for business um if it were
up to me we wouldn't make any videos
because i they just don't seem
they seem kind of pointless um i want
people to hear the music not see the
music and
then get planted in their heads kind of
what what they
what they think this like i want people
to to
come up with what the songs about
themselves that's why i got into music
in the first place
great thoughts on that uh
i mean i for me i think i mean as a
music fan which is really
what i am to begin with um i was never
i i i'm a big fan of listening to music
you know i think that
uh but i do understand you know youtube
is obviously a massive part of the way
people consume music yeah
i don't want to sound like a dinosaur
either
videos are cool um
youtube is a you know is a massive part
of the way people consume music today
and i
and and i actually i think it's one of
the um
i think it's one of maybe a uh
future of the business or or of music in
general is how people experience
music and and i think there'll be visual
aspects to it
i think that's one of the great things
about you know rooms like this
and and places like stanford is there's
all kinds of tech
technology and and innovation that's
going on that's going to make music
more experiential in in my opinion and i
think
video will be part of that in some
fashion um
and then you have you know youtube and
and and the phones with screens and
and certainly there's a there's a whole
lot of music that gets consumed with um
that gets interacted with through video
but at the real core of it you know
what at the at the very very core of it
the great songs and the biggest songs
and
and and the biggest artists have an
ability to move people and make them
feel and think and or both at the same
time through a song
without a visual yeah and i mean
um i think that through the publishing
world of things as well
you know we got a lot of breaks on our
first uh hit song
just by it being um on the tv show glee
and then being in a chevy commercial so
so
you know it's a nice it works as an
outlet to get your music
out it definitely works
on a business level yeah i think that's
that's actually an interesting point you
know
there's also a lot of uh use of music
with visuals
that come later or for another purpose
or you know whether it's a movie
or a tv show or a commercial or any of
those things
where we don't actually make the video
that goes with the song but for some
reason
uh you know it can be a very powerful
combination
great so let's imagine there's someone
in the room or someone who's listening
who so wants to be a professional
musician you know they're they this is
something that really is their passion
and they want to have this broad
audience how what's the best way for
people to
think about the process of getting quote
unquote discovered
that question is like asked all the time
and uh there's
the cool thing i think about this this
answer is that there's
no rhyme or reason to it you just
uh i think you you if it's a good song i
i hope that
that um through through publishing or
through record labels you know it'll
it'll find people uh the internet has
been so helpful
in in that making making people
discoverable
i will also say that if if your
goal is is to get rich and famous then
you might you might have picked like the
wrong
the wrong profession so cameron though
do you go and troll
on youtube and see who gets a lot of
views i mean you know i mean are you
like
youtube looking for artists
or does someone have to get introduced
to you i mean he's usually just
writing a really a bunch of snide
comments about beyonce's
attire but we know that in the world of
venture capital
in the publishing world there are all
sorts of unsolicited business plans and
manuscripts
and things don't get read unless they
are introduced i mean do you have
a network of people that you count on to
introduce you
who are out there looking for talent or
are you out there you know
literally are people looking on youtube
to see who's getting views
i think there are there's different
approaches and there's different ways
people do it so there's again there's no
one way anything happens
but i um we have people doing research
and most companies do have people doing
research
and obviously you know this is a so we
have people doing research and
and that involves lots of different
things there's a lot of tools that we
have
um you they use you know in technology
we can see
um believe it or not you know we have um
uh companies and and internet
capabilities that allow us to see
every radio station how many songs how
many songs they play what time of day
they play our songs
we can see when things sell by market we
get lots of data
in a lot of different ways and so we
have a research department
that works through that data and and
will look for things that are working or
not working
an area that could probably use a lot of
help and a lot of work frankly
is how we how we find new talent how we
find talented people that are connecting
with an audience
because um you know that's one way to do
it um
but also i think for me personally um
you know a more informal network of
people that i know
and i've got to know for many years some
of them are are
you know everything from people who work
in studios to people who
work as in as lawyers or managers or
booking agents or whatever
and also then just stuff that gets sent
in and of course there's the friends of
your parents and the friends of your
brothers and the friends of your
you know i mean everybody knows somebody
so um
but you know the reality too in my life
with all of the people that
i've been fortunate enough to work with
you know there's
basically two real truths to it one is
that
um you know i've been fortunate that all
of the success that i've had in the
companies that i've worked for have had
is really um at the core
based on creative people writing great
songs and making great music
and secondly everything that i found and
ended up working with
i was brought to me by somebody else so
i've never actually
trolled anywhere and found anything
specifically
but that doesn't mean it's it's not just
you know one or one person in the room
or two people playing me something or
somebody i know sending me something
and ultimately you know you still have
to make the decision are you in or are
you out
and that's that's the real challenge
that
right i bet there's some questions in
the room who wants to start
yes and say it really loud okay
um so you said that you're trying to
make the transition from being a record
company
to being a music company um so obviously
a lot of the money that was in recorded
music
has sort of transitioned elsewhere is
this
primarily in live performances and
touring now
or what are the markets that you're
trying to go after in the music room
uh well yes a lot of them there's
there's probably
more money in the live recording
business i mean in the in the live
touring business than there's been
and i don't have it in front of me but
um
yeah but i would say it's more nuanced
than that i i think we're looking at
things
like um like
you know streaming services like youtube
like new video services
how do we organize around that how do we
monetize our music in those situations
our videos in those situations
what's the best way to run a business
around that do we
sell our own advertising do we use
somebody else to do it do we
have an algorithm that does it how do we
create more videos to go with that
what's the business around lyric videos
you know i'm
sure you guys experience a lot of lyric
videos there's a lot of
lyric websites yeah what's up with lyric
videos
a lyric video is a video that that
basically plays the lyrics of the song
while the song plays
on youtube like on youtube very popular
um
so i can sing along you can sing along
or you can or you can just read along
yeah it's like a karaoke type of
situation yeah so you know i think
in in all of those places where we're
trying to figure that out
um and how do you organize a business
around it what's
what's the best way forward do we want
to be in the in the live business as
well i mean we as a company
um in certain instances share in the
live performance
of the artists in some instances we
don't um
you know how do we how i think what you
know how do we partner more with our
artists and connect them to more
to more more fans are there
what are the global opportunities around
an artisan around music what's the music
you know what are the opportunities are
how are people going to consume
music in eastern europe how are they
going to listen
are there opportunities that are
different there than they are here
are you know how what's the relationship
like with the fans
those kinds of things right yes
so when i was growing up there used to
be like four major record labels
and now there's only three three main
players yeah what do you attribute
um to one disability so you mean one of
these three main players
can you please repeat the question just
you can repeat it
oh um
now there's three major record labels
what's what capabilities and what
ability do we have to remain
i think you know well look there's
probably a number
of things one is the incredible history
of the company and this
and the scale of the music that we
already uh
are in business with and the artists
that we have but i would say
um you know going forward our ability to
find new talented artists and connect
them to fans our ability to
help them succeed in in doing that
that's really the lifeblood and the
future growth of
of our company and and i would also say
you know innovation
and the culture of the company as a
whole how to how do we
how do we continue to evolve you know on
on the warner chapel side a 200 year old
company
that's still thriving how do you you
know how do you create a culture how do
you continue to have a culture
that attracts young people that attracts
smart people that's innovative and it's
thinking
that's flexible in the way it approaches
business so that it can survive
you know whatever whatever the world
throws at us and i think that's you know
as a as a leader of a company
um of the size and scale of of warner
brothers in warner chapel
that's the real challenge is is how do
we create how do we create a sustainable
ongoing
business and business culture that's
attracting people
to help us to drive us into the future
yes hi i'm wondering if you're looking
at new artists
um how important is talent versus like
an image or a brand
so the question was how important is
image versus talent yeah
it's interesting because um
you know i guess uh sometimes
i'll uncertain two ways first of all
talents is very very important
and it's been proven to me over and over
again and i think there are times
you know there are times in running
especially a smaller company not so much
running warner's but when i had my own
businesses
that are smaller you know you ebb and
flow with your own success
and i think i was cons it was constantly
proven to me
that that talent finds its way
and that that's uh that's
something i fundamentally believe in i
think then
images you know image and how does that
you know i guess i wouldn't always
separate the two i think
often times the talent and the image are
connected very closely
so a lot of great artists that i meet
and a lot of
people that i meet they have a kind of
almost an innate ability and
a feel to have an image that's
genuine and is themselves and
but also connects with people so i think
it's a vitally important part of what
they do
but i don't think it's necessarily
people have talent or they have an image
mustaches mustaches they got a little
bit extra it's great
but so you know i think they they come
together okay
over here yes hi
how do you think warner brothers and
artists should be compensated for
the streaming services like pandora
what will be your ideal way to be
compensated for that
so the question had to do with
compensating artists for streaming music
such as on pandora yeah how would you
ideally like to get
as much as possible
i think that was the right answer that
that i mean that's our our job is
at times but no i think that the the
reality is pandora's a very interesting
case and
and um uh probably one that could you
could
you could put a whole a whole class
around um
in terms of how it works it with our
industry how it interacts and
and what the right way to get paid is
but i think really how i would answer is
you know
uh on a broader scale is we want to be
we want to be paid fairly
i think warner's wants to be paid fairly
we want our artists to be paid fairly
we can argue about where that point is
you know
but i also would say that we
you know we want to encourage innovation
we want to encourage new businesses
to to use the content we want to
encourage uh new investment
and new listeners and and creative ways
for people to experience music and for
for fans to connect with artists and
their music so
you know the end there's a lot of
different views on how that can best be
done
but um certainly we've taken the
approach and i believe that um
you know we're pretty flexible in how we
do that we we encourage people to
to get into business uh and use the
music
great back in the way back
so i have a question about
pirating and i'm curious what both of
you think because
you're veterans in this business and so
i know a lot of musicians
and i usually what i'll ask them is how
they feel
about being pirated and it's usually
musicians who are just getting started
or maybe been in the business not even
the business really but just been doing
it for
you know a short while because it seems
to me like
the way that you get discovered nowadays
is
you know a lot of a lot of people
discover new music through
piracy and uh it's almost a way
to measure how relevant a new artist is
by how many people
are are looking for that person's music
and so
and the other thing is uh you know if
you have if you have these uh private
piracy sites such as pirate bay or
torrent sites
and they're making a profit off of the
artist's music
why haven't director labels just started
you know instead of a a
piracy network just start giving it away
instead so the question really is about
piracy and
and what the attitude is and how the
record industry or warner
brothers record is uh dealing with this
well i get asked that question a lot um
just as an artist how i feel about it
and i think that it's kind of a
you know it's a little bit of a catch-22
and in that um
it had not been for piracy uh probably i
probably wouldn't have gotten
where i am and and um and then at the
same time it's kind of a direct because
i i've
i've always bought my own music and i
bought my own music because i i love to
own
an album i look at it a lot more
artistically than uh
anytime i get something for free
personally um
i usually don't end up listening to it
it feels a little cheap to me
and and i think that
that people should take take pride in
ownership of art
uh however i i can't
i think it's done as much it's probably
done a little more good than bad for
for someone like me whereas if you're
the
the record label
passing yeah i mean you know
it's a tough thing for us as i don't get
paid no matter what that's what i'm
saying
uh i would you know look it's a tough
thing for us the piracy
you know there's a lot of places you can
get free music i guess
you know some of it depends on what you
call piracy so you know bittorrent sites
from
from overseas that are just giving away
tons of free music
uh you know that's a really challenging
one for me i don't see the benefit of
that
to anybody um but if you're talking
about free music
you know or people being able to to to
get music for free i think there are
times when that's beneficial and
certainly we as a company
engaged in a lot of free situations
whether it's
you know promotional type stuff whether
it's giving music away through various
sites
whether it's freemium type models with
spotify and
pandora or other places where we allow
people to use it for free for a period
of time
and then they have to pay us after at a
certain point
so you know we we've taken a lot of
different approaches and a lot of
different looks i think
you know there's there's a continuum of
piracy too and i think there gets to be
a point where
where my feeling is we should shut it
down
but i i think that there is also a lot
of use to free music on the internet
right over here thank you so much
uh i'd love to hear what are the so
being in the music industry i'm sure
that you're also
looking at how internet is changing
other businesses as well i'd love to
hear
what firms outside of the music industry
you're looking at and things that
they're doing that are interesting that
you're looking to apply to the music
industry
so the question is um are you looking to
other industries for inspiration
um to for the music industry
yeah yes we're looking all the time and
we're
we're looking at them from different
points of view and
uh you know it's it's it's hard to be
the expert on
on everything in the music industry but
i would say that uh
so i don't speak for everybody but you
know look we look at all a lot of
different companies from
and and how you know how they're using
technology everybody of course from
google and apple
and and and the huge companies to to
smaller companies
you know instagram snapchat whatever the
whatever the
the latest ones are um
and really what we're the you know
fundamentally
we're still you know our approach is
how can we how can we either change our
organization
and change our company as a whole in
order to better compete going forward
or how can we use these various
technologies or
or or partner with these companies to
connect
more fans to the music that our artists
are making so
we generally approach it through through
those two things
and when we do that the the
possibilities become
fairly infinite um and we're constantly
looking
to try to to try to do that i think you
might have seen
just today or yesterday we announced a
wonder music group partnership with
shazam
to you know source talent to find new
artists to use their data
um in helping us move forward so
you know they're obviously a big
technology company but big or small
we're looking for companies we can
have strategic partnerships with and or
be in business with
right yes i've heard that you studied
law before going into the music
insurance wondering what prompted that
change
so the question is cameron you were a
lawyer you studied law before this and
then you entered the music industry
what prompted you make that change uh
well a lot of different things but um
you know i studied law i went to
business school and then i went to law
school
i became essentially a criminal defense
lawyer
um and a litigator and uh
really i wasn't prepared for it i wasn't
really emotionally
able to do it i wasn't prepared for the
negativity
i wasn't prepared for the misery and the
negativity around it
frankly i i like the intellectual
challenge of it
and when it really when push came to
shove i'm sure it's something i don't
know if it's something that
maybe it doesn't happen at stanford but
for me when i was that age it certainly
happened is that you know
uh it's hard to find something that
you're really passionate about
and that to me i would look to the re at
the rest of my life i remember when i
was a lawyer at times i think my god the
rest of my life doing this
you know and and i didn't see a lot of
really happy people
um and i just didn't have the passion
and the belief
that what i was doing was really that
meaningful at a period of time
and so um
i'd always been a music fan and music
had been probably
uh music and sports had been the most
important things to me in my life
to that point so really i started the
record company um because i just
felt like you know if i could be a part
of bringing music to the world that
that affected people the way it affected
me that would be a good thing and that
would be a worthy thing to do with my
time
my energy and so that's what i did
great last question i'm really curious
when you and your team are deciding to
sign a new artist
what portion of your personal taste goes
into that decision and
what part of that decision is made by
you know reaching a certain fan base
reaching a certain type of audience
filling a hole in your roster so to
speak
so the question is how do you when
you're evaluating a new
artist or new song how do your personal
tastes come into play
versus looking at more strategically and
how it fits a
fits a hole um that's a good question
all these questions very challenging
these are about 100 times better than
your like the questions that i get on a
daily basis
you should take this one since a random
radio station like wants to know like
how fast can you run a mile
i'm not going to answer that today
everybody's too intellectual
so i'd answer the question this way i
it's a it's a really good question
um when i had my own business uh
i would say you know if this was my
personal taste and
and this is the records that we thought
would sell
you know we were trying to do this
so now that i now that it's a much
bigger company
and um fortunately i'm the chairman and
the ceo
we have a team of people and and
hopefully that they are finding things
because you have to have that
i think somebody has to have that
passion for it and that desire for it so
we try to have a
a variety of people who can answer that
question
you know um better than me but i hope
most of them sometimes they're going to
show up and and have a real reason for
wanting to sign
a particular artist or have a passion
for it and be willing to stick with it
and sort of and stick with it through
thick and thin or um
or find a way to make it work you know
find a way to connect it to fans find a
way to connect it to an audience
because um you know that that's it so
i as far as the company at warner's goes
my personal taste and what i
particularly want to do
um is not necessarily a deciding factor
although sometimes um you know
remarkably i
i appreciate and like a lot of the music
that's wonderful note to note to end on
um
i hope you agree that this has been
really fascinating and given us a
view into a very different industry than
we normally get to look at
if you're interested and curious to
learn more about creativity and to
polish your creative problem solving
skills through the lens of music
i encourage you to take a look at this
new online class that we're working with
them on
if you go to online.stanford.edu you can
get all the details
and please join me in welcoming or
thanking our fabulous guests
you